what's happening you bad [__]
uncle joey here with the joint it's
wednesday the 8th of september the joint
is brought to you by
zip recruiter listen to me everybody's
excited
places are reopening people got to go
back to work now unemployment is done
you want a job absolutely every place
is hiring right now forbes magazine says
jim's hotels salons are set to go on an
epic hiring spree in the next couple of
months millions of jobs will be need to
be filled as businesses
start reopening how do you hire people
fast are you ready for this one
zip recruiter try it for free at
ziprecruiter.com
joey j-o-e-y
you have nothing to lose
here's the difference with zip
recruiting you're not just posting a job
and waiting for some resumes from joe
schmoe to come in zip recruiter has
fancy technology that finds the best
people
for the jobs it tells you who's most
qualified and invites them to apply
right now you can try ziprecruiter for
free
joy what are you talking about you can
try zip recruiter for free at
ziprecruiter.com
joey again
that's ziprecruiter.com
joey try it for free
just by going to ziprecruiter.com
joey listen whether you got a small
business or a large business zip
recruiter can help you
they'll get you the qualified candidate
quickly you understand me but it all
starts with you
that ziprecruiter.com
joey again
ziprecruiter.com
joey the joint is also brought to you by
upstart do you hate looking at your
credit card statement every month now
you know how i feel when you're in debt
it can feel like it never ends
upstart can help upstart is the fast and
easy way to get a personal loan
to pay off your debt
listen having debt sucks the holidays
are coming kids are going back to school
you don't want to be broke right now you
start with a little loan you consolidate
and by the holidays you'll be jumping up
and down
whether it's paying off credit cards or
consolidating your debt get a simple
fixed monthly income
over one million people have used
upstart to get out of debt so do me a
favor
find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com joey again
that's upstart.com
joey gotta throw in the disclaimer loan
amounts will be determined based on your
credit income and certain other
information in your loan application
but go to upstart.com
joey
and get out of debt today it starts with
you upstart.com
showy yeah i'm excited about the soprano
movie coming out but i gotta be honest
with you you know what i'm really
excited about
beside my daughter going to school
beside her playing softball it's
football season [__] and from the
heart of jersey the joint is brought to
you by draftkings
listen you got the jaguars the texas you
got the charges at washington i smell a
tremendous [__] parlay it's the best
day of the year [__] sunday september
12th draftking sportsbook the official
sports betting part of the nfl is giving
all new players
[Music]
a hell of an offer you understand me bet
one dollar
on any nfl game and cash 200
in free bets instantly no matter what
you heard me right that's free money
better dollar
and get 200 are you [__] kidding me
or what listen the nfl season is coming
you want to be prepared [__] all these
other [__] jokers draftkings is the
best service out there they're the
officials betting partner of the nfl
and the [__] ufc and we're just
getting primed up for a tremendous fall
winter of sports whether it's college
football pro football ufc
college
football i mean listen
baseball the playoffs come on now
draftkings has everything plus they got
a tremendous online casino but it all
starts with you if you're looking to win
some money in a nice and easy way do me
a favor download the draftking
sportsbook app today use promo code joey
to receive 203 bets when you place a
dollar on any game
the first opening weekend of the nfl
that's promo code joey to get you 203
bets instantly
the official sports betting partner of
the nfl
you got to be 21 older new jersey
indiana and pennsylvania only new
customers only restrictions do apply see
draftkings.com
sportsbook for details
if you got a gambling problem do me a
favor take care of it call 1-800 gambler
if you're in indiana call 1-809 with it
but if you're straight draftkings has
the answer for you they are the best
service out there i love using they are
tremendous download the draftking
sportsbook app and it's time to win some
gears draftkings preston joey
put a dollar down and win 203 bets
let's get this [__] started
welcome to uncle joy's joy
[Music]
so
what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday the 8th of september
a beautiful [__] day to be alive
uncle joey here looking good feeling
good smelling good i'm showered the
balls are pouted it's going to be a hot
one today the [__] pool is closed so
i can't even refresh you know what i'm
saying like all these [__] pools
closed because there's no nobody to work
them the kids went back to college the
pool's usually open until [__]
october it's gonna be 90 today and i got
to [__] ride my bicycle like a
[__] bumpy but today's the last day
of mercy's i'm not having [__] school
so at least i got the whole afternoon
with her and then tomorrow
back to [__] school
hopefully the numbers won't get bad here
in jersey
and she could stay in the whole [__]
year with no problems they gotta wear a
mask what are you gonna do you know what
i'm saying
i'd rather
i'll [__] wear a mask and go to
school i mean she doesn't want to zoom
either
so she wants to go in there and be the
belle of the ball
let her have a [__] great time
uh everything else that's going on i
haven't heard much from the kate quigley
situation my heart still goes out to her
and the families of the other guys that
uh that passed away i don't know
what's going to happen or what's going
to be done
i thought i would hear something
yesterday after the holiday but uh
it's still very quiet and like i said my
heart goes out to her
i can just imagine how she feels she
probably feels embarrassed i mean
three people died around you you know
i know she answered red band back and
stuff so at least i'm just happy that
she's okay
i'm happy that she's responsive and i'm
happy that uh
she's still with us you know i'm uh
i'm a little concerned about a future
and what's gonna happen you know
we never know if the cops are gonna show
up or who's gonna show up
i just hope the situation passes her
as quickly as [__] possible
labor day was sensational
i had a great time i went to say goodbye
to all my buddies at the [__] pool
it was heartbreaking i had to
listen that [__] pool did more for me
this summer than anything i did yeah i
get
i'm having a great time at therapy with
better health but my real therapy was
that pool this summer and it was meeting
new people and branching [__] out and
i had a great time i had a great [__]
time you know i became you know like i
said everybody i became friends with is
over 60. i'm getting ready to go out to
my [__] pasture with these old guys
but they're all great man i'm happy that
i [__] got to hang with them and talk
with them but the guy that stuck out the
most was this kid that's on the spectrum
we i befriended him and he became my
friend and he was a great [__] kid
he's 32 years old
he swims five [__] miles a day
he does a hundred laps a day and this is
an olympic sized [__] pool you know
the kid's got a lot of heart and then he
walks three hours
around the [__] place this is what
you do when he's serious about [__]
uh his health and that [__] got
no covert he's darker than [__] from
being out in the sun every [__] day
and he would inspire me man i'm i would
go out there and i would i'd go out
there with my [__] joe diaz [__] the
water's too cold and he's like [__] you
get in here it's beautiful it's
refreshing it's supposed to be cold and
he made sense to me so i would go out
there and jump in the water with him i
didn't care how [__] cold it was and
i'd swim because he'd hold my fire to it
you know he'd hold my feet to the fire
so
but
you know like i met him like in june and
we started talking little by little you
know i never you know i never bring my
stuff out there you know what i'm saying
like i i when i was out there i was cool
there was a lot of kids there so i
didn't want to be like a [__] jerk
off
but i became friends with him you know
and i would talk to him one day he told
me he was smoking cigars and that he
liked smoking weed and [__] i said you
like smoking weed
well i'll bring you a little something
you know what the [__]
and i brought him some [__] uh
laughing gas i brought him a little
butter laughing gas and i said roll this
up you know i didn't bring you know
rolling papers or whatever
the [__] next day i went there and he
latched right on to me he goes what was
in that stuff
oh my god i was high from four in the
afternoon to 12 30 at night i just sat
there and looked at the tv and it was
turned off you know all that [__] i was
[__] dying
i'm like oh my god i can't believe i
gave [__] weed to a kid on the
spectrum and he [__] loves it look at
him he was happy as [__] it did him
great so yesterday what i did was i said
[__] it let me uh
bring him a guard and i bumped into him
and a couple direct things and [__] he's
just a good guy man i needed to meet new
people so that's what i did i went out
and i met new [__] people so
yesterday i went there and i took them
you know i took like this two old guys
to smoke weed
and there's you know my friend that
smokes weed so i brought them all a
little butterweed
and i brought the dude on the spectrum
my friend josh i brought him
a [__] edible like a 10 milligram
starburst
you know
let me tell you something
he was so [__] happy
he goes to me when do i do it i go
tonight he goes forget the night i'm
gonna do it right now and he ate it
right there at the pool at one o'clock
and he goes what do i do to get this
thing going i go why don't you walk
around the pool a couple times and
that'll get your heart going he [__]
started walking around the pool i didn't
get a chance to say goodbye to him when
i left he was [__] walking jack he
was he was walking for about 40 minutes
so he must have been [__] up he pulled
an owen benjamin on me that [__]
was walking from here to [__] new
york state and [__] so i loved it i had
a great day over there and then i went
to my friend's house where my wife and
daughter were with the kids and they
were throwing a tremendous [__]
barbecue
short ribs korean style with the [__]
oh my god
[__] burgers hot dogs shrimp with
bacon
[__] chicken wings these
[__] threw down jack
i brought him a few [__] edibles and
i went over there and i sat there i
didn't jump in the water
but when i went to his house this is the
weirdest thing i was sitting there and i
had a couple of shrimp with bacon
you know he wraps around the bacon
around the shrimp and he puts on the
grill nice
and i'm sitting there and they're
talking [__] and i'm just listening to
him and next thing you know
i'm like i don't [__] feel right you
know
i don't know what the [__] was going on
with me
and i felt like puking at first i'm like
[__] well why am i feeling like puking
for and all of a sudden
like i started sweating [__]
profusiously
and i'm like [__] i'm never gonna make
it inside it was hot outside i'm
sweating profusely
and i'm like i gotta tell all these
people to go and get my wife and [__]
uncle joey's going down at this [__]
party
and all of a sudden like i was like i
had my head down praying to god please
don't let me faint right here i mean i
wasn't like i was gonna fall i was
sitting down so i was just [__] you
know it was like somebody shot me in the
head and i just fell down like the dude
and [__] uh american gangster i'm
gonna do that shoot himself at the end
detective lupo he shot himself and he
just goes down nobody knows
that's what i thought was gonna happen i
was just gonna faint
and i'm laying there and i look up and
my wife i look up and there's my wife
coming at me and as soon as she looked
at me she knew
she goes are you okay i go no
and she goes let's go inside she [__]
carried me not carry me my wife can't
carry me i'm a fat [__] she just you
know help me inside
and when i sat down i started sweating
let me tell you where i was sweating
from my [__] elbows and my arms like
nobody sweats from out here my wife was
like what the [__] is this
and then a droplet fell off my finger
right to the [__] floor and i was
like jesus christ so
i drank some water she put something
now who knows
what the [__] happened you know
this is my life lately welcome to my
[__] life
i just pass out of the [__] barbecue
you know what i'm saying that's
that's the new and improved joey diaz
for you but i'm okay
you know whatever it was maybe it was
the heat maybe it was
who the [__] knows a leftover edible
maybe somebody put some fentanyl in my
[__] milk
who the [__] knows i don't [__] know
what happened to me but i just had a
moment
listen it's [__] september and i'm
excited for a few things first of all i
love the fall i love september in new
york and new jersey
it's absolutely [__] beautiful but
there's something else i'm excited about
i'm ver and you guys notice
it's just a broken record now i'm just
[__] speaking to the choir
i'm very excited about the many saints
in newark to me
it's a feather in my cap it's not just a
movie it's a
it's an accomplishment
i don't look at my life with a lot of
accomplishments you know i've had a lot
of good moments
and i've done some good things i've done
some shitty things and i've had some bad
things happen to me but accomplishments
i never graduated college i never
graduated high school i never graduated
eighth grade nothing like that
this is something i'm very proud of i
don't know why it's just a stupid movie
if you want to call it that i think it's
a work of art
and i always wanted to work for david
chase and i got the opportunity and i
came through with flying [__] colors
so
i'm very proud of everybody involved in
this project you know i actually
obviously i loved the show with all my
heart
and i was a true fan of it you know i
told you guys last week that
on monday that i took my my daughter to
the movie saturday
and i saw her enthusiasm and her
excitement you know and at one point she
was drinking
an icy slush whatever those things are
and she was throwing sidekicks and
punches at the screen and [__]
and then when we came home
she broke down
the whole movie to my wife in five
[__] minutes
you know and we were both me and my wife
were both [__] laughing and i'm like
you know what
she's my daughter because she's a
[__] movie buff you know she loves
movies she doesn't she always says i
want to go say that she doesn't care
who's in it she doesn't care where the
actors in it she doesn't even look at
things like that
she looks at them as i'm going to have
some [__] fun you know and i remember
she made me think about that like how
much fun i had at the movies i grew up
at the [__] movies every saturday i
was the movies every friday night i was
at the movies you know the cinema 48th
street the mayfair theater cena dhoni i
went to all those movie teachers new
york city fairview the [__]
binghamton i saw 48 hours
splash
[__] fairview i saw [__]
apocalypse now the evil that men do
[__] union city cinema i saw [__]
the longest yard
the original i saw rocky in that
[__] i mean i'm a movie buff
that i i never knew
that i had what it took to be in the
movies but i was also i was always a
movie buff
this many saints of newark has brought
the movie buff in me out at the age of
58 years old
so for the next couple weeks on this
podcast
we'll be surprising it up whether you
like it or [__] not okay
whether you like it or [__] not we're
gonna soprano this [__] up maybe take
an episode or two
dissect them maybe get a few guests from
there
dissect them and we're gonna talk a lot
about as much as i can
talk about the many saints in newark you
know it's going to be released here and
24 [__] days so we're all [__]
excited here so
uh today's guest is uh
the star of this movie this movie has a
couple [__] stars
and he for one
i mean in my world everybody's a star in
this movie except for me everybody's a
[__] star
seriously you know i'm not a [__]
star i'm just a [__] fat [__] that
cracks jokes
but uh i want you guys to feel good
about it but today's guest
is uh michael gandolfini
i hope you enjoy him he's a great
[__] kid i'll be back afterwards stay
black enjoy
[Music]
oh ho
mikey g what's the story i keep doing
what's happening buddy you look [__]
dynamite oh thank you man i appreciate
it you're looking good you're like
blowing
you're what your skin's glowing what
kind of face routine you got going on
huh no no refill all [__] day
just to join at night i'm getting some
good sleep
there you go i'm drinking a lot of
[__] water
i love that and uh vitamin d you know
jersey vitamin d mixed with a little
pollution it's the best a little cancer
in the air it's good for you i love that
smell when you land like when i get back
from la and i land in new york like the
smell of like new york pollution and
trash like i love it it makes me feel
good it's in my blood
there you go
it's uh it's quite i like when you're
driving on the turnpike
and you get that whiff that those
[__] odors of new jersey like
and you see that stack blowing the
[__]
smoke into the air and god knows what's
up there in the marsh you have like the
marsh and who knows how many bodies are
buried in there
i do know how many bodies are buried in
there there's a lot
in fact i saw a foot sticking out the
other day on the 18 i'm like i'm not
even gonna bother that [__] it's
funny we were driving on the 18 the
other day my daughter goes dad i just
saw a bear
and my wife is like let's pull over i go
[__] pull over what is this a zoo
ain't no [__] zoo we're not pulling
over nowhere yeah
no way i love that
i love that how you been
i've been good brother i've been good um
you know getting ready for the movie to
come out i've been doing all this sort
of press which is like so incredible and
so
weird and like talking about myself a
ton it's such an interesting [__]
experience it's like
i don't know i feel like you know like
i'm just a normal guy so it's so weird
to like um
you know have all just answering all
these questions about me and my life
it's it's been
tough and fun and hard and scary and
exciting and all that stuff
good how does it feel to be less than a
month away
from being in one of the best films of
the year
oh man um
i'm excited i'm just like excited i'm
really
i'm proud of what we did man i'm really
proud of it and uh you know that's the
feeling i have and like proud for
everyone to see it and can't wait to get
everyone together it'll be like our
family reunion you know how are you
feeling with it coming out
i'm uh
this has been a great experience for me
from the beginning
all the way to now the shooting inspired
me to move back here
yeah just coming back for that movie
inspired me in a way they go what the
[__] where have i been
what the [__] am i doing with my life
living out in la i'm ready for jersey my
daughter
needs it um the set was one of the best
sets i've ever worked on in my life
it was no drama you know another la
[__] on the set you could tell the
big difference between shooting in new
york and la is a big big difference
everybody was dynamite we laughed our
asses off there were long days you know
but they didn't feel long like i've
worked on movies before where you're
like this sucks yeah this was coming
home at six feeling like
you just went came back from an orgy you
know just
like i believe there going holy [__]
that was great today you know
oh yeah david's directing and you know
what you learned from him and just
everybody everybody it was just a
phenomenal experience and uh
i saw the movie and when i went to see
the movie
i had expectations
i don't know what
the words i'm looking for are
and i was blown away
it was really blown the [__] away to the
point that i sat there for like five
minutes
going what the [__] did i just see
yeah and i think the biggest takeaway
i got from the movie was how good you
were
how good you came through
how great your arc was
your article you got to remember or
i only did one scene with you we never
saw each other you never saw each other
you were always off duty when i'd see
you that was [__] yeah i know whatever
so we were never together except for
that scene
and that was john scene so we had
nothing to do in there
so i never really got to see you till i
went to the movie and i was like
on the drive home i was like that
[__] better be ready for what's
coming his way after this man i i really
i
i really really really appreciate that
you know especially coming from you and
it's a testament to you guys i leaned on
every
one of you and like you said like we
didn't have a lot of scenes together but
all of us who are a part of it like
david
david is
such an incredible artist not only in
his writing but like in his casting i
mean he created a family and i got to
lean on you guys and that's what i did i
just leaned on you guys and learned from
you guys and
um like you said like you know a lot of
people sometimes ask like was it super
intense was it hard and like you say of
course it was hard and intense but it
was a [__] blast like it was so fun
we left our asses off you know i mean i
we were doing 14 15 16 hour days but on
days that i had off not every day but on
some a lot of days i had off i'd come to
set i just wanted to watch like i wasn't
gonna not watch you guys and get to
watch these incredible actors and people
work like i loved just being on set it
was the best you know
it was the best i really uh
learned a lot from david
like i was a big fan of the show
but i like the humor of the show like i
have always said the uh
when they do the intervention with
christopher
that is some of the funniest [__]
things i have ever seen and i'm a pink
floyd i'm a pink floyd pink panther guy
i'm a pink panther guy i love the pink
panther and that's what that reminded me
of like oh when paulie goes to the
psychic and he throws the chair oh my
god oh my god there's just so many
[__] scenes that are
hilarious that you really laugh
and i remember
it was my first day on the set
and we had to do a scene
and i was doing the comic thing i was
trying to improvise
and i remember somebody came over and
they went
don't do it just sit and learn
and i remember doing it
exactly how they wanted me to
yeah and all of a sudden i was in the
twilight zone i was in the soprano
episode yeah because david is the king
of silence yeah he's the king of making
silence like when you're a stand-up
comic
you come from a school
michael that you tell a joke and it
should vibrate
and then it comes back to you
but let the joke sit
don't step on it and a lot of comics
including myself
you know you're on a roll so you just
keep hitting them with [__] left you
know with hard right hands
it's great once in a while to hit
somebody with a right hand and just
settle yeah and see what damage they
take just from the one right hand and
that's what david chase is the master of
yeah so it added a different component
to comedy wow that's real comedy that
david chase
yeah a lot of people don't look at it
that way yeah i've never that's
incredible i've never really thought
about it like that and
you know like i also i just have to say
like you
are so good in this movie you're so good
because the thing that
david did which
in many
ways you'd think was impossible but he
you have this whole plot line the
movie's about dickie and it's about
the 1960s and 70s what it was like to be
a mobster during that time what it was
like to be in the
sharks skin suits and the hats and the
guns and
what it was like back then not it's a
mob movie and then there's also the
sopranos in it and the soprano
characters but
first and foremost it's it's a mob movie
between you know leslie and alessandro
but
you
really represent
both worlds in a really hard way like
your humor
and humility comes off so
it's the sopranos like you're so funny
in it and enjoyable and you're laughing
while you're crying but you also
represent
a real
60s 70s gangster and what it was like at
the time so i think that was super hard
to do and you did it you know so
i remember all that [__]
you know i came from cuba in 66. yeah so
i was already in the bronx in 69 70.
yeah and i still remember going around
the corner you weren't allowed to go
around the corner and i used to go
around the corner and see those men
sitting in front of the italian place
yeah and i still remember walking past
him to go get an italian ice and losing
my [__] mind
because i'm a cuban kid eating a cherry
italian ice
are you [__] kidding me
and then going back two days later to
get sherbet with sprite
yeah yeah when they used to put in
because it was like a a [__] place
where you got egg creams and yeah yeah
yeah and ices and [__] like that totally
yeah and i still remember going over
there and them talking to me
mm-hmm and then like spicaroo you know
what i'm saying like they call me a
spicaroo and [__] and be like what's
going on and so
i saw all that in the 70s you know i i
remember the 70s
a lot of people don't they're not old
enough
the 70s were a lot of fun the country
was very free you know new york city was
on
fire i had my mother had that bar in
jersey since the 50s
oh really yes on 29th and bergen line in
union city holy [__] so i've been going
you know that's where the tony pro was
you know it was a big uh i think uh
henry hill talks about union city and
his goodfellas book they used to hang
out at the bottom of the barrel
it's a big little italian neighborhood
that cubans moved in
by 1906
it became
the second biggest cuban community in
the country but it was still wrapped
around irish and italian yeah yeah yeah
so i got to see all that stuff the
cadillacs and the [__] you know the
convertible cadillacs the three miles to
the gallon
yeah yeah because that's all those cars
give you is three [__] miles to the
gallon you better have money on the
lecture 225 you know all those
so i still remember all that stuff and
it's uh
i think david represented it
tremendously in this movie
um this movie's gonna
scratch at people a little bit you know
just the the newark stuff that a lot of
people that know about you know
yeah i mean it's it's super
important and just like a testament to
what's going on now you know like
it just never went away i mean 67 was
this this hot summer you know like there
was these
protests across
all of america and this in the most
violent one being the one that actually
happened in newark
um
with uh you know the cab driver um
john williams smith i think was his last
name but it's it's kind of incredible
how it's still just a testament of
what's happening today you know
it's intense well when i watched it it
was weird i it struck a chord with me
with the you know with all the stuff
that happened last year i mean it would
have really
scratched if it came out last september
as it was supposed to
you know
but i think the movie's still tremendous
i i was talking to my
mercy's godfather last night and he was
telling me my daughter's godfather
and he was telling me that he doesn't
know if he wants to see the movie until
he watches the show
because he works so many hours my
daughter's godfather and
i go the movie stands alone
it really does
it really does like i've been watching
my wife has been watching the episodes
again i
catch half of them i'll come down and
catch 20 minutes
and it's just like the other night we
were watching one and it's so weird how
much
like my wife is a christian from
tennessee
she can't find a [__] christian
church around here like she can't find
one
you know so she's she's a catholic we
got her over at [__] uh
you know saint gabriel over there
and she's like i don't understand that
so we already like i didn't care what my
daughter what religion my daughter was i
really didn't care
as long as she has some type of faith
you know she's not a [__] heathen
but uh yeah i don't wanna you know you
gotta believe in something you know yeah
yeah so uh
when she said i can't find the [__]
church i got to put her in catholic
school i was like that's cool and i i go
with them now
i actually go with them my daughter
signed up for
you know ccd she already completed the
week she's going to make a communion
next year
that's amazing it's so [__] weird and
the sopranos is wrapped around
catholicism yeah the episode i was
watching the other night carmela was
talking to a priest and she was in
confession
and then there's always a funeral
you know i've been here for [__] a
year and i've been to three weeks
already
a year i was here a month
and i was at awake already
damn i was here two weeks and i got
invited to a [__] wake yeah so the
sopranos really
embraced everything that's jersey i'm
[__] jersey bro totally i don't know
if you know this i was you know raised
in new york till the third grade
and i'm a new york city guy i love going
over there not anymore it's a little
weird now
but as far as jersey's concerned i'm a
[__] jersey guy and like i told david
i go david bruce springsteen
and bon jovi couldn't put jersey on the
map
you put jersey on the [__] map
it's true no i mean
he
i think for all of us it was a really
you know that there
there's something weird where like i you
know i grew up in new york and my whole
family lives in jersey and i always kind
of
been in jersey like every weekend and
spend all my summers in jersey
but there's this odd sort of jersey
pride that i feel i love in new jersey
um and
i think you know
it
it's a great state and it it
where you're from is so important
whether you're from new york or new
jersey or tennessee or california it has
a lot about who you are and
um
you know
david
really has such a pride for new jersey
and gratitude and
i think that's why
he he focuses on those details the
people and the family relationships and
the locations like even the mall like in
the surprise like the mall is a very big
thing in jersey everyone goes to the
mall you know like that's a big thing in
sopranos and church and the pressure of
church and
half your family loving church the other
half of your family hating church and
you know like it's just it is very
jersey and it's it's important it has to
be you know there isn't any other place
that david
would know to talk about in such a
poetic and incredible way
i gotta tell you i'm very proud of being
from new jersey
but this movie pushed it over the top
for me
yeah i have to really be on this was my
stripes
this is my biker jacket
you know this is my
uh
it's funny he said i was again my wife
was watching it she's been watching now
for about two and a half months
so i try to play the guitar while she's
watching it and [__] cuz i've already
seen the episodes back and forth
but sometimes i'll come in and she's
watching the last episode a couple weeks
ago she was watching the episode when
carmela had to visit the guy in uh
college at columbia
he took her out to lunch to try to
and uh
to try to get the 50 grand from her and
she goes i didn't know you were from
jersey i didn't know you were italian he
goes yeah ross
short for rosetti you know
and he goes uh something about the
jersey school system i've always been
[__] proud about the jersey school
systems i think i learned
you know i'm [__] a savage from the
jersey school system because they didn't
just teach you about school they taught
you how to get over how to get free milk
they don't [__] around new jersey they
had a driver ed teacher
that he we used to talk him into
stopping and getting chinese food that's
part of the [__] education
yeah of course we used to [__] sign
up at a quarter to 11
to make sure he would have the car you
know we would be with him until 11 30.
and we would talk him into come on mr
mcgrath you got to stop a chance yeah a
couple stakes on a stick come on we know
you're hungry
we'd get the steak on the stick and make
sure he'd eat one first so then we
you're guilty you know what i'm saying
now you can't rat us out we're all good
but there's something about
being from jersey like i told my when i
got here last september i took my
daughter around the corner and right
away i remembered kids in new jersey you
ready for this
most kids go out to play in new jersey
you won't have to die
like
when i was a kid in new jersey i used to
give my mother a hug and tell like i
left the will i left a little note under
the pillow
my trains and my hot wheels because i'm
going to die yeah we were kids in new
jersey you didn't go out to play [__]
whatever you went out to die like god
forbid some car pulled up to you when
you were playing stickball and wanted
you to move you know how many [__]
fights we got into as kids with people
driving cars because who the [__] are
you to drive down the street right now
it's two outs we got the bases are
[__] loaded we got the puerto rican
up at bat and you want to [__] drive
here now get the [__] out of here come
back in 20 minutes go [__] yourself and
we [__] jump the guy and next thing
you know so
there's something about jersey there's
something about being from brooklyn yeah
there's something about being from the
bronx there's something about being from
harlem but there is something
from being from jersey now you went to
high school in studio city correct
yeah so i you know i grew up
in in um so my whole family lives in
bergen county and then i grew up in
manhattan and jersey going back and
forth my whole life
and then we moved out to l.a um in uh
in middle school so i was in middle
school and we moved out and i did middle
school and high school in la
and then i turned 18 and went back to
new york for for college and uh
and now i've been back ever since you
know i'm an east coast boy um i [__]
love it here and i and yeah i do agree
like i think that
after doing this movie there is a
certain odd pride about jersey that i
have now that i never had before um
just a real a real love for it so yeah
like i said as i was shooting the movie
then my days off i would take the ferry
over
and
i got reacquainted yeah i got
reacquainted i took a couple rides with
my friends
bergen county
and i said what the [__]
am i doing out there
and
it was just a process of when can we
make the move back yeah and what a lot
of people didn't know was we were
supposed to come back and shoot
well you had started shooting already on
the 9th of march
well i did it yeah it was the last day
before we got shut down which is that i
it was the phone booth scene
um that was the scene before we got shut
down when we really had re-shoots yeah
yeah
yeah that was the the scene and
um then we got shut down and
we kind of were all just waiting you
know for [__] forever um and
september came around and we we did
those reshoots those last couple scenes
did you did you ever get to shoot in
jersey nope
yeah i know we me and david you know we
i know david really wanted to shoot more
in jersey
i got to shoot
i believe
two days in jersey and i remember
it just felt different there is like
something really special about it
beginning to like
i was just so happy we got to shoot a
couple things in in new jersey it just
felt really right you know what i mean
it was awesome when i got the movie i
was very excited about hanging out in
newark
yeah i was like [__] we're going to
shoot newark yeah i haven't been to
newark in months they got the spanish
kitchen
yeah great portuguese section they got
great italian food they got a couple
cuban restaurants
we'll go out at night in newark you know
and then when we got here i didn't have
newark at all anywhere in my shoot dates
and it didn't depress me i didn't i was
just listen
i was just happy to be a part of it for
me
michael i was just happy to be a part of
it i knew it was going to be something
big
yeah i knew it was going to be something
special
when i heard you were in it i really
wanted to be in it and uh you know i
didn't know i knew john
yeah you know but i didn't know like
sam i didn't know
little paulie corey i didn't know a lot
of those guys [__] samson i love that
[__] all of them all of them you
know
[Music]
uh ray liotta was great to shoot with
him he was [__] dynamite you know
he was dynamite and i gotta tell
for people who don't know he's another
guy that did great in this [__] movie
i think his character was [__]
tremendous i think david hit it out of
the park with his character
yeah everyone everyone i'm just so proud
of everyone they're just everyone's so
so good in it and like
to have such a blast i mean
for not not one of us [__] hated
anyone like do you know how rare that is
like not what there's gotta be one guy
that like i can't stand that person like
it wasn't anyone like it was just the
best
how did so how did you
did you audition or did you just get it
offered how did it come your way
i found out he was doing it
i thought about it for like a week
and i contacted john
john i don't have the script nobody
knows you know i knew dave wasn't gonna
have a script out there i knew david
wasn't gonna have the right lines out
there i knew david was not gonna
give you lines from the movie at all or
anything
so i just
i thought about it and i talked to my
agent
and they sent the
sides you know and i looked at the sides
and there was a trick question
in the sides
what was it it was a trick
it was it was a
it was a uh
just the way he did the line yeah i was
supposed to react to it a certain way ah
okay okay and at first i looked at it i
didn't know what to do
but voila
yeah i thought about a scene with silvio
and your dad god rest his soul
and i go
that's the scene
he's referring to i'm gonna do this
nice and i did it and i sent it
and i had i had no expectations because
you really can't read somebody off the
tape
especially for that film
so i really had to think about my
audition i really had to work it out it
was just a couple lines it wasn't even
about the thinking it wasn't even about
the lines
it was more about what i was going to
put through that camera what i wanted
david to see through that camera yeah
yeah
so i did a slate
i spoke about jersey i knew that he
wanted somebody from jersey and
you know he wants the spirit of jersey
he wants to smell jersey authenticity
yeah so i let them know and then i put
the audition online i did the little
silvio bump
and uh
about a week later they contacted me and
said there's a little interest what do
you think blah blah blah and then
believe it or not
i was ready to turn it down
why
because i was going to be away from my
daughter for too long
i was like it's two weeks and then i got
to go back for another two weeks like
it's going to be a pain in the ass
yeah i got these dates like i was still
[__] and all sudden tom papa
this comedian named tom papa i spoke to
him
and i'm like i don't know and he goes
are you [__] stupid
you can't be this [__] stupid yeah he
goes that's david [__] chase even if
the movie is a bomb
he goes you still get to work with david
chase you're gonna learn something yeah
and i go you know what you're right and
i knew this all along like i was dying
to work with david yeah yeah i knew this
all along so i was like [__] it
let's do it you know how did it come for
you
oh
i
uh
i had heard that they were gonna do a
movie i was like okay you know i'd never
seen the show i i kind of was not really
a part of it it was my dad's thing so i
just kind of
you know was going to college and living
life and then they
said there's going to be a younger tony
and i said okay great
um who's amazing in the movie william
and then they said there's an age jump
um and there's gonna be an older tony
and they want you to audition
yeah you know and
i had the almost the opposite experience
where my hesitation was at the beginning
of just kind of you know
i was scared i was like well
i don't know should i do it i don't know
if i could do it
um
a lot of pressure
not even regards to like the all the
dad's stuff is one layer but also the
layer of like playing tony soprano i
want to do it authentically i want to do
it right it's a very complicated very
important character to a lot of people
and can i do this
and
one of the things is like what can i add
like i didn't know i thought
86 hours of tony soprano what new is
there
to say or do
and i got the sides
um
i was like carmine i was like i was
auditioning i was like who the [__] is
carmine i was like i thought i was
auditioning for tony
and
uh and i told you he always throws a
curveball at you throw the curveball and
uh
i uh
went in
and my you know my manager at the time
was like it's it's doug able who's
casting he's a great casting director i
was 19
maybe even 18 at the time during my
first audition
which is crazy
and it was he's a great cast director so
if anything
i nee it's good for me to get in front
of good casting directors in practice
and that was kind of like the goal in my
head like don't worry about any of this
other [__] just
go in front of a good casting director
you'll learn something
you don't have the part whatever so i
went in
did it and then over probably
probably like three or four months i
went in
i think three times um and the last
audition was with alan and david
and similarly to you
i did the audition and um
david was writing a scene
that he hadn't
he had taken it out and put it back in
and taking it out and he was he just
wasn't sure
and he was like can you read this just
cold read it you know we're thinking
about putting in the movie but i want to
hear it out loud
and uh
like you i got it
you know i've never seen them before i
didn't work on them but i knew
exactly what to do
i was like
i i know i know the tricks in here i
know the jokes i know
when to be serious when do because the
thing tony's very bipolar he's
he cries he gets angry and then he cries
and then he laughs at himself that he's
crying like in the span of 30 seconds so
like you have to just
be able to move wherever i want you know
what i mean you have to be able to to
get angry and then
laugh at yourself and you know like
i had to have all that i when i knew
that i could be handed a page
that david wrote and this incredible
scene and know how to do it
that's when i sort of was convinced like
okay i can do this i can do this um
and then
[Music]
when i heard
holy [__] like alessandro navola and
john bernthal and vera farmiga and corey
stoll and then we got to meet samson
who's an incredible actor in alexandria
and like all these incredibility
and ray like i just was like
this is the greatest gift for a young
actor to not only play
such a complex and hard
and exciting character
but to also get to learn from all of
these people like
it was this the best it was the best
i uh
was blown listen it takes a lot
to blow my [__] wig off
okay it takes a [__] lot you know
i'm an old man
you know i've been doing this for a
while
this blew my [__] wig off
okay so
i can't imagine what it did for you man
uh it's
it's a great sitcom
it made history david [__]
you know if you thought biggie kicked
down the
walls [__] david ripped him off the
ground you know
david is [__] hurricane either you
know like he just doesn't [__] around
dude
yeah so
i was i'm very proud of this
it's the reason why i moved to jersey
yeah like this is complete i could come
back here now and hold my head up high
i'm very proud of myself for being in
this movie i'm proud of myself
for behaving the way i did on this movie
you know like just
it was such a fun time but i was a
professional i knew my stuff and i
worked hard
and uh i got to meet some great people
and i got to meet you you know and uh i
think you're a sweetheart you know and i
want all the best for you it's so weird
what you look like when i met you and
what you look like today like
i remember talking to nicole
one time and going when are we gonna
[__] shoot this and she's like you
think you got [__] problems this
kid's getting older by the day you know
what i'm saying we gotta shoot this [__]
he's starting to grow hair he's starting
to get tall you know and i'm like oh my
god i never even thought of that you
know that he's growing so yeah i got to
meet you i you know this has just been a
tremendous and now
like i'm starting to hear from people
like i heard from sign from samson i'm
hearing from you know john yeah like
september 1st everybody woke up from
their [__] slumber no we did yeah i
got i mean vera has been calling me john
we're gonna all be together it's gonna
be it's gonna be amazing it's gonna be
amazing so we're doing the 23rd at the
beacon 22nd i'm here it's a tuesday or
wednesday
i don't [__] i think it's a wednesday
wednesday yeah that sounds right
yeah it's gonna be i mean to have all of
us together again it's been [__] 10
years it feels like yes it has let's see
let me double check this so the 22nd is
a wednesday that's right
so we're doing it the wednesday the 20th
and that's not a premiere that's just us
no i think it's a premiere i think it's
like uh it's a
there's gonna be yeah it'll be a
premiere a real real whole thing
i think they're still trying to like i
don't have tickets yet but i think
they're still getting them out to
everyone and yeah it'll be a whole thing
that's gonna be
[__] dynamite yeah like i'm sure the
cast
i hope the cast of the show will be
there and we'll all be together it'll be
[__] amazing so they're doing a
festival here on the 27th and 28th
in new jersey oh cool one night at
monmouth uh and one night in eatontown
i spoke to the guy and he said to pass
the message on that you're
invited to both of them to do a q a
i'll i'll give you a call this week and
let you know the guy's name and
everything i forget the name of the film
festival um it's small you know it's
like the one night it's 1 20.
yeah the other night it's like 300 seats
and uh monmouth uh
and they're gonna do an early screening
i was thinking of going to the one and
eating town yeah let's go together
see some people say hello answer some
questions whatever the [__] they need
there you go have a great time uh
i'm also thinking of going to guns and
roses this week
no way
yeah they're gonna be here saturday and
sunday in atlantic city i heard they're
incredible they're incredible i want to
take david and let him rock out and [__]
but
i don't think he wants to fly in for
that i love it
betty loves your guns and roses i feel
like that's totally his taste yes so you
know this has just been a great
experience i'm happy you took the time
to be on here today i love you with all
my heart i love you uh i gotta tell you
something i miss your dad and i never
even met him yeah i miss him and i never
even met him i went out and bought the
drop
yeah dvd so i could watch him because i
love him in the drop yeah
i love him and i love him in the
sopranos but i love him in the drama i
love him and get shorty i love him and
everything so uh
i know that you had your shoes filled
in this movie and you stepped up
to the [__] pump and hit it out of
the park i'm very proud of you
i love you and i can't wait to be with
you and watch this movie on the big
screen we're gonna have a good [__]
time it'll be amazing thank you very
much for taking the time uh
i just wanted to see you and talk to you
a little bit and check in with your
brother son made me so happy any time
any time you need me i'll be there all
right the joints gonna love this i love
you brother have a great weekend
and i'll see you in a few but i'll give
you a call on that festival yeah give me
a call it'll be fun okay you got it
brother stay black bye bye
what's happened you bad [__] i
hope you enjoyed my little tata tay
with big mike when i met him he was just
a kid uh
and he was a great kid we left our asses
off on that set
uh he ain't lying we had a very good
time on that set
it was very enjoyable
david chase was a pleasure to work with
alan king was a pleasure to work with
nicole was a pleasure all the other
producers were a pleasure to work with
i'm just if you know anything about me
i'm not i'm not just saying this
i had a really good time and i know a
lot of you guys
are waiting on this movie so
that was michael gandolfini that was his
take on it
i hope you enjoyed it and uh i will keep
you guys posted next week we'll have
another guest from the movie or the
series
or whatever we'll [__] just talk
about it just to get you fired up for
this [__] there's still a few
tickets available for the beacon theater
so if you guys want to go to the beacon
theater i think the tickets i don't know
what they start at
uh he clarified it for me today he
thinks that's the premiere i don't want
to lie to nobody and tell you you're
going to a premiere or whatever
but uh tickets are available there's not
a lot left but
go on the uh
beacon theater website and they'll help
you hook you up
laughing gas is back in stock
why [__] around
when you could smoke the best if you're
in the california area
go up to the ice cream shop and pick up
a little bit of laughing gas and [__]
have a good time jump up and down with
your friends
and beside that that's it i love you
[__] with all my heart
it was another fun-filled week and as
you could tell
i'm coming back little by little i'm
making my little comebacks and [__]
i'm getting better i'm getting happier
and uh it's all thanks to you guys and
the support
that you guys have given me throughout
the last year thank you very much have a
great weekend i want to thank michael
gandolfini
but most importantly i want to thank you
guys for always having my back
and for supporting the podcast i will
keep you up to date on the uh k quigley
stuff i love you [__] stay black
have a great weekend and i'll see you
monday morning tip top [__] magoo
ready to go and now for a word from my
[__] sponsor jack
all right you bad [__] i want
to thank mikey gandolfini for coming on
today
and giving you guys a little love but
before i go i got to talk to you about
something you hate looking at your
credit card statement every month so do
i
when you're in debt it could feel like
it never ends
upstart can help
they take into account your history
your income and your employment history
this means they can offer you smarter
rates with trusted partners listen this
is the time of the year you don't want
to be in debt right now you want to get
out of there upstart is a fast and easy
way to get a personal loan to pay off
your debt
whether it's paying off credit cards or
consolidating your debt get a simple
fixed monthly payment so you know
exactly what goes out and what comes in
every month upstart is tremendous unlike
any other lenders upstart looks at more
than just your credit score they take
into account your income and your
employment history this means they can
offer smarter rates with trusted
partners just a five minute online rate
check that's it you can get approved the
same day and receive funds as fast as
one business day if debt is taking over
your life
it's time to get a fresh start with
upstart that's why they called up start
do yourself a favor
find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com
joey that's upstart.com
joey
don't forget to use our url to let them
know i sent you
loan amounts will be determined based on
your credit income and certain other
income
information provided in your loan
application go to upstart.com
joey and get out of debt today the smart
way by consolidating upstart.com
joey this is the smartest way to go get
out of debt today
the joint is also brought to you by
draftkings the first sunday of the nfl
is here joey when this [__] sunday
where have you been take your [__]
head out of your ass it's the best day
of the year [__] christmas i'm bringing
you christmas four months earlier hi
uncle joey with draftking sports book
app the official sports betting partner
of the nfl giving all new players a hell
of a [__] offer whether you just
spent a dollar on any game and cash 200
bucks and free bets joey what are you
talking about bet one dollar on any
[__] game
and cash 200 bucks in free bets
instantly no matter what you heard me
the first time free [__] money bet a
dollar and win 200
don't piss me off i know you got a
dollar and it could use 200 [__]
friends draftkings is the best in the
west it's safe secure and reliable you
can take your money out at your
convenience which is very important plus
they have an online casino that's second
to none you got college football you got
baseball baseball playoffs come on now
it's time to win some money it's the
fall slash winner download the draftking
sportsbook app today use promo code joey
to receive
203 bets when you place a dollar on any
week one game that's promo code joey to
get your 200 and free bets instantly for
a limited time only at draftkings
sportsbook app the official sports
betting partner of the nfl now you got
to be 21 over new jersey indiana
pennsylvania and anywhere else where
it's legal
new customers only apply to this action
restrictions do apply see draftkings.com
sportbook for details now do you have a
gaming problem let's take care of it
call 1-800 gambler if you're in indiana
call 1-809 with it
and they have all numbers for every
state that you're in but if you don't
have a gaming problem this is the best
way to go
because it you can you pay before you
bet it's not like you're gonna have to
catch up on thursday that's why i'm
telling you to download the draftking
sports book app
and start winning some money today
quickly use code joey j-o-e-y to get the
party started
one dollar wins you 203 bets where
draftking sports pick app i want to
thank draftkings i want to thank zip
recruiter
and i want to thank upstart oh i didn't
read zip recruiter tremendous you want a
job every place is hiring right now
millions of jobs will need to be filled
as businesses
reopen and as the unemployment gets cut
off [__] you little
nerds with your money getting free money
from the government every time i go to a
restaurant i gotta wait an hour for
service because you [__] are
lazy it's time to go back to work [__]
and ziprecruiter.com is here to help you
you have nothing to lose here's the
difference with ziprecruiter you're not
just posting a job and waiting for
resumes from joe schmoe to come in
ziprecruiter has fancy technology that
finds the best people for the job and
helps you get them it tells you who's
most qualified and invites them to apply
it works get two and a half times more
candidates this way
four out of five employers who post on
zip recruiter get a quality candidate
with them the first day
why what are you waiting for
go to ziprecruiter.com right now right
now i'm gonna let you try zip recruiter
for free joey what are you talking about
it's wednesday free
you need help and i'm thrilled i'm
showing you some love what's rule number
one of the joint make somebody's day and
that's what we're doing right now
go to ziprecruiter.com
joey that's ziprecruiter.com
joey
j-o-e-y try it for free
just by going to ziprecruiter.com
joey zip recruiter the smartest way to
hire again i want to thank upstart
i want to thank zip recruiter and i want
to thank draftkings
for having our back but i want to thank
you guys for listening and supporting us
i want to thank michael gandolfini for
coming on board today and rocking our
[__] world and i love you [__]
the many saints in newark is coming out
and i'm excited i hope you guys are
excited too
i'll see you [__] monday
tip top magoo ready to go it's back to
school week [__] i can't take it
no more i love yous have a great week
and i'll see you monday morning ready to
[__] go have a great weekend
[__] stay black uncle joey loves
you
i almost forgot the goddamn candle
um
[Music]
so
you